[Music]
so
i think kanye's is supposed to release a
new album
really but with all the new [ __ ] that's
happening with him
who knows if the album's ever gonna come
out it has to come out it will come out
do you think so
a lot of people need to do that you
think his breakdown
and i want to hear more than ever
spectrum uh is
a political political stance is all
for the release of his album i think um
he he's actually going through it you're
really really really really
real yeah because i know i'm thinking
this is real now
i think it's i think it's real i think
when he's in the state
he's so creative with everything he's
like i'm gonna do an album i'm gonna run
for president i'm gonna do this
so we'll just all coincide at the same
time it's a manic statement yeah
it's not like he's doing this and then
getting i'm gonna go crazy for everyone
and then
i'm it's gonna give me so many views of
mine okay i think i know a lot of crazy
people
yeah um and i've seen some crazy right
and when i see this guy i'm like he's
not
that crazy well it's not have you seen
the videos
yeah like i know what he's saying so i'm
not okay i just think that he just sucks
at explaining
and he's just passionate but i don't
think he's okay when i think of crazy i
think of a guy
that's giving you a hug and then he'll
kiss you on the cheek turn around and
say
why did you say you're gonna [ __ ] my mom
and then stab you that's that's
that's a different mental disorder so he
has bipolar disorder
yeah different and i've seen well
bipolar like we saw an episode just like
of bipolar and where it can go right
but in his case i'm not saying that he's
not bipolar i'm just saying that his
threat to society and how damaging he is
i'm i don't think it's that harmful like
people are saying it's harmful i guess
that's what i'm trying to make
people are saying it's harmful because
of him running and then taking votes
away or him whatever right right but
with him being
harmful to society it's not like he's
gonna go and hurt people and do that the
most harm
it could be only to himself yeah so like
something that really triggered some
people out there
was his latest rant about harriet tubman
if you haven't seen that
you know he did the 400 so that's the
secret move
when harriet tubman
well harry and thomas never actually
freed the slaves jesus had the slaves go
work for other white people y'all we
leaving right now
and that went viral dude did you see the
the the driver in the back he was like
what the [ __ ] y'all for real
so people think that that's harmful
right and
i guess i'm i'm crazy too because when i
look at that i go
that's actually good when he's when he's
telling people like well
he just sucks at explaining things right
very much because
the way i would say it is like okay um
you know sometimes in in in world
history i mean sometimes in our history
classes
they'll pacify us by saying like hey
like racism doesn't exist anymore
because guess what harriet tubman did
she saved this
uh uh she freed the slaves but he's
solved now but he's like we're
we only went from one slavery to another
kind of slavery like
now we're in we're in debt now we're
salary slaves now we're
you know he goes we might be free we can
buy things we can vote we can do all
these things but he's like
in reality we still have owners and
people don't understand that
it's like you think they look at you
like you're crazy if you
if if you say that we all have owners
then like literally the whole no one is
actually free in this world
and that's what he's really telling
people and people like oh no
they're talking about the literal
chattel chattel slavery right
and then i'm like is he really losing
his mind though because
who's who's who's the crazy one here
the one that doesn't want to admit that
they're uh uh
you're basically uh we're all slaves to
somebody
like whether it's debt or whatever or if
we have to work for the sake of money
like we we're asleep to money we're a
slave to
yeah we can't like a true free person is
a homeless person
he does whatever the [ __ ] he wants he
walks around he
picks an orange from a neighbor's yard
he eats that and every single day could
do whatever he wants
what's the thing that people are the
most pissed about though so like
um yes i think everyone's always gonna
be a slave to something you could be a
slave to your passion you could be a
slave to your salary to
whatever right even to your family i
guess you could be a slave to anything
the real slavery and like harriet tubman
free people from the
the slavery of slavery yeah
yeah like so that's what people i guess
view as the taboo slavery being a slave
to [ __ ] flaming hot cheetos isn't
what people are pissed about right
so like i think um going from
from saying what he is what it seems
like to the normal person if they don't
understand them or if they
just take his words literally just
sounds like harriet tubman did nothing
for the slaves back
that's and that's why they're pissed
right yeah yes that's why they're pissed
um
were you asking yeah so i guess like um
if that's why people are pissed but if
that's not what he's talking about
then what don't people have an aha
moment and they
came in to say that that's he he can't
he hasn't spoken to say that's what he's
saying no but like
for me when i watch this we know what
he's saying as he's saying it i go
okay he's talking about this slavery and
in the split second i go he's not
talking about that
you don't know that right no no no for
me i'm talking about my my viewer
experience
so that's how i take it so i'm like for
other people
uh are they only stuck on this side
same way the same way that you're you're
stuck on hearing it this way right now
we're
again kind of like what we did in a
previous video where we talked about
what anytime
the person has to fill in the blanks for
what you're saying
you're already [ __ ] up but he no we
didn't fill in the blanks though because
in here he said
um they just went to we they just
they just went to another form of
slavery yeah so if you play it back
he goes he didn't sleep uh uh well just
if you play it back and forth he didn't
free enslave she just got them to work
for otherwise
she did it yeah so she so so so he's
working for
other no no he's working for other white
men
so basically because he's also awesome
when harriet tubman
well harriet tubman never actually freed
the slaves
why are people not talking about that
she just had
them work for other white people she's
she didn't literally
hire them and smuggle them and give them
to white people what he's saying is like
they're not really free they're still
having to work for a master
now it's just for money so then so then
like
he's it's not filling the blanks he's
saying that like they're working for
other white people right
why why is no one talking about that and
saying like
because he said a very very um heavy
statement
the anti-anti-what you learned right
which is she didn't free the slaves
those are the exact words and people are
taking his exact words right plus
it's that plus he all the other things
i've seen the longer clip
and it's literally just like him talking
and then because he brought up harry
tunman his mind went to
let me say something else about harry
tubman you know and it's like for for
that sake it's like without context
without anything yeah uh he didn't have
context for bringing that up
yeah it's almost like saying like adolf
hitler's a good man
and then everyone's like what he made
the volkswagen and yeah then it's so
like yeah so it's like
i addressed the first statement what the
[ __ ] did you just say right that's where
he that's
with what's going on in his head the
last episode he was talking about
how um slavery is a choice slavery was a
choice that's right that's
uh and then i think he was probably
talking about maybe it's like a mental
thing that you put yourself in right
but victim mentality right i think his
main problem
is he doesn't know how to explain [ __ ]
but he's also going through a manic
episode
you could tell by everything he's
posting he went on crazy rants online
yeah
another aspect to this whole
chris they basically i'm like in get out
right now get out was based on my life
yeah
um they're trying to put me in a
hospital but they uh [ __ ] them they
can't find me she tried to kill my
daughter
um come and get me i'm in the ranch or
something and like
basically being like he's going through
it again right what do you think kylie
smells like
something he said he he called
chris chris jenner chris
and then like yeah you should start name
calling everyone in the family tweets
that's weird they're finally doesn't
have chris reputation with
keeping the men saying yeah i'm not even
saying that what this guy is
what kanye's saying is right or wrong or
whatever it's really about
um what he's trying to communicate out
there to the world
i think that we should have a
conversation around
these messages uh whether it just sounds
crazy or not right because what people
are doing is they're just getting
angry at the fact people that they
that's what's happening and people
especially to look at him well shouldn't
we be angry at the fact that
that you know we are all enslaved
through debt well but you don't wanna
you don't wanna
kanye isn't the person that stimulates
those kinds of
conversations and thoughts you know what
i mean he's a musician
if it was someone that had more
authority in the space then i could see
more people talking about it because now
he has the credentials
but that's the problem see him as that
like beacon of
truth or knowledge so that's the problem
that i have
where um everyone knows
that i try to stick to a diet most of
the time right not today
not but there's [ __ ] chocolate and
[ __ ] doughnuts
it just jumps in your mouth root beer
floats
i have a [ __ ] problem i'm gonna start
[ __ ] eating that [ __ ] right
if it was a normal person you're like oh
this guy's a [ __ ] problem
but you know it's bar and so that's kind
of normalized for bart
right so to me the problem is
kanye if he's gonna have a breakdown
that's already the kanye that i know
the fact that people are breaking down
because he has a breakdown
that's the part that i'm like why are
you guys having a breakdown as if he is
supposed to be normal
right because you know this is the kanye
that you know so it's like these videos
that are going viral
are by people that are like hey i'm
gonna go there because i
i can't wait till to see what happens
because they're like i'm i'm trying to
capture what he says some crazy [ __ ]
cause they're not going there because
he's going crazy though and like they
take his word as like a beacon of truth
and all that stuff is because of the
fact that he has so much
influence because of the fact that he's
a public figure so people are trying to
hold him accountable to the fact that he
has that influence
and so yes like he might be going
through a manic state and
people like we should also be viewing
that perspective
and seeing like oh we needed to be
talking about mental health too
and like how it's being stigmatized and
how kanye is being called
crazy and all this and then so it's like
so many issues being
like highlighted right now with this
whole situation
so like part of me i'm like dude i feel
for kanye also i'm just like joe like i
can see like what he's trying to get at
it's not being well communicated people
are attacking what he's saying
because i think is the fact that they
are like you're
you need to be accountable for the
influence you have but he's also just so
to me i'm like he's just
exercising his first amendment rights
right he could say whatever the [ __ ] he
wants to go if you want to go
and pay and go watch him speak that's on
you
if you want to hear some really
insightful deep [ __ ] and you go watch
chappelle
that's on you who you choose to go
listen to speak it's on you
and who you let affect you it's also on
you yeah
so so for me that's why i'm like don't
blame him that you're [ __ ] riled up
you're just riled up like if you if now
i'm laughing at him because i'm like if
you're scared he's gonna steal
votes then do your part and don't vote
for him yeah vote for the other
parties you know right yeah plus it's
like it's like that with everything it's
like
okay you you purposely went and got mad
to watch him but i'm like
if you want to watch a racist video you
just type in anything on youtube you'll
finally
get mad at oh but it's not your fault
it's not it's not who you want
it's not popular to be mad at right now
so it's like it's that
i do think also the position he's
placing himself in like you know running
for president then people get held
like up to a different standard like you
know usually
they get held up to a different staff i
mean donald trump won that's why he said
usually
with him being the exception and when he
comes out in a security vest
i'm already looking at like a really bad
school play this guy's supposed to run
for president he comes on a security
vest i'm like okay this is that's
that's us you know it's almost like
sasha baron khan doing another stunt
yeah i think for the black community
though they're probably like
why the [ __ ] are you even trying to set
us back again
that's like us and william hung i mean
we have one
you know but i'm like there's probably
someone looking at us like why are you
sending us back
exactly yeah joe's the best right now
i'm in the [ __ ] best baby hey
that's 100
that's our friend's company he's putting
us forward bobby hunt is pretty
supportive i think
on the mental health side of it i think
like to be able to
get him to have help because he needs it
just anyone with that you know it's like
he does need help though he needs
something he is going through something
and it sucks that it comes out this time
but it's like he's only doing these
things because he's going like
when we had another friend that went
through and he had his whole thing on
youtube when he went through a whole
he wouldn't have done that if he didn't
go through it and you saw and maybe he
was speaking truth i mean he didn't
really talk about anything but it was
just
i don't know about having drank over was
truth though yeah but there was a lot of
other things where it was like
um well that one came out of like
[ __ ] almost choked
manifestation
but then um let's see it makes a lot of
people choke this week but
i think with just like with everything
that's happening with him going through
that it's like
oh [ __ ] he's he's gonna say some off the
cusp uh
things that probably he's not gonna work
properly and people are gonna take
it away plus no one's gonna take
anything like jio said like you have to
make sure they understand and if they
take it the wrong way that's probably
your fault and that's what i mean like
so when you see
me eat right and you're like if you
don't know me you know like
i thought so supposed to like be on a
diet why the [ __ ] is going crazy but
you're like okay i know who bart is
right
so same thing with him because i know he
has like uh stuff he's already dealing
with
i try to every time kanye comes on i try
to give him an extra layer of empathy
an extra layer of trying to really
understand he has
mental health what does he really try i
can't tell the history of it yeah but i
almost feel like there's
also people that get riled up they
whoever amount of empathy they give to
their friend when kanye comes to speak
and he needs the most of it
they already i'm gonna reduce my empathy
i can't wait to judge i can't wait say
some crazy aha there it is
well it's also like the media helps spin
it spin that too
and like make it even crazier yeah the
media is horrible
yeah the media is which makes me kind of
believe him when
he he started going off on in that one
concert and he was like
i don't have my handlers anymore and
like he stopped taking his meds
the only person that came to help him
was dave chappelle oh yeah dave
chappelle flew to him
to still dave chapel one of the guys
that we know to like
in terms of media to go against it and
be like yeah [ __ ] this you know like
this is all like
this they're putting basically making me
a slave again yeah
it was like i'm out i did back to africa
[ __ ] dude
but for better for worse kanye please
release your album because i want some
more music oh he will
because the people that are his handlers
there because they're gonna make sure
that he they
he makes money we need some money
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million
years in the making but we finally got
just kidding news
merch yep so make sure you go down to
the store below
and you can bring around wow yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you